thank you
um good evening everybody and welcome to
this strategy and resources committee on
the 10th November 2022. for those of you
don't know my name is counselor Sue
White and I am the chairman of this
committee members we're streaming this
meeting live as well as recording and by
being present in the meeting you're
giving your consent to being recorded
during each item please put your hand up
to indicate if you wish to speak I'll
then invite you at the appropriate time
please note that YouTube live stream
sound recording is dependent on the
correct use of the microscone phones
therefore if I can ask you when invited
to speak you remember to turn on your
microphone and turn it off when finished
please listen to page or paragraph
number when referring to the agenda
papers and keep your contributions as
clear and concise as possible and I will
apologize for wearing a mask but I
recently just tested negative for covid
but I thought I didn't really want to
breathe on anybody while I was here
um right so moving on a gender item two
we've got apologies for absence and I've
got councilor Bassinger and councilor
Durham who has got a substitute for
councilor Fleming councilor Fleming
welcome to this committee
and do we have any others
nope they're the only attention
thank you Tara okay moving on to agenda
item three we've got minutes of the last
meetings we found on pages 5 to 30 which
is to consider them it's the stretchy
resources committee held on the 6th of
October 2022.
um does anybody have any queries or can
we agree them on block
agreed perfect well done okay moving on
to a gender item four to disclose the
interest and nature of any disclosable
the canary interests other registerable
interests and non-resistible interests
relating to items of business on the
agenda having regard to paragraph 9 and
appendix B of the code of conduct for
members members are reminded that there
also requires disclose any such interest
as soon as they become aware should the
need arise throughout the meeting
so do I have any
um
interests
cancer Channel
thank you madam chairman it's going to
be a bit difficult to describe this
fully because it relates to one of the
um items which won't be um I have to be
disgusting in private and confidential
how it does relate to gender item number
22. and it relates to one of the
appendices and should a discussion ensue
on a certain specific element of one of
those appendices then I've decided
looking at it I feel much happier it's a
non-registerable interest I believe
having read all this bump and getting
confused but I've decided I will
actually leave the chamber should on
that particular and I will declare my
interest now that I'm a member of a
charity which used to be called National
Association of Crohn's and Colitis it is
now called crows and Colitis UK and it's
relating to that I'm a member of that
and I also will disclose but not the
detail of it due to other things I have
a protected characteristic thank you
madam chairman thank you councilor China
do I have any other interests
nope okay uh moving on
um right agenda five public
participation to receive the views of
members of the public of which prior
notification and writing has been
received
um do we have any public speakers
tonight
thank you thank you Tara okay moving on
to a gender item six um budgetary
control as at the 30th of September 2022
on pages 31 to 38. and if we could have
Mr Leslie um give this report for us
please over to you
on the 6th of October the committee
received an update on the budget
forecast for this year I will outline
the key budget points and key changes
from the previous report as well
the approved Inuit supplementary
estimates of 229 000 pounds remain the
same as previously reported
taking the budgeted use of the general
fund Reserve at the start of the year
the approved total budgeted drawdown
from the reserve now stands at 681
000 pounds
the largest budget variants is around
Staffing with a 272 000 pound variance
due to the higher than budgeted pay
Award of 5.25 on average Ledger contract
income is also lower than estimated as
costs increase and income remains below
pre-covered levels
since the previous report the level of
investment income has been revised
upwards due to an increase in interest
rates and an additional 104 000 pounds
more than budgeted is now expected
additional income in recycling and local
tax collection is also expected overall
the forecast shows their variance in
excess of the budget of 138 000 pounds
that's one percent of the net surface
expenditure budget
the forecast use of the general fund
would now take the reserves from 5.8
million to just below 5 million still
above the recommended minimum of 2.6
million
okay now members I will say if we could
keep our questions quiet if you've got
anything you'd like to mention because
we've got a really long agenda
um and the recommendation is that the
committee notes the forecasted 2020 to
2023 financial position as at the 30th
of September of this financial year but
before we um put that to the vote as
anybody questions I'd like to ask
councilor siddle
uh thank you madam chairman uh yeah I
would just uh like to thank the finance
team for the good reports that come
forward to the committee now uh I think
it's really important that we support
our staff and we give them decent pay
Rises uh and we try wherever possible to
match inflation because we need to
support support our hard-working staff
through the cost of living crisis as
much as anybody else the other question
that I have is uh in terms of the
Leisure are we working with the Leisure
provider in terms of trying to recruit
more membership for the Leisure
facilities in the district
Mr Lindsay yeah thank you chair
so in terms of the Leisure contract we
have a uh Leisure contract working group
which uh meets we've recently had
figures through from our Leisure
contractor
um and speaking with our consultant
we're actually seeing that the recovery
rate is
um in line if not above and I think the
contract you see was actually above
where the rest of the market tends to
sit so in terms of the overall recovery
in comparison they have been performing
quite well albeit the overall the
Leisure industry is not recovering to
pre-covered levels as quickly
um as one might hope we're also looking
to give the working group a bit of an
update on actually the activities that
they are doing as well around that and
um
and that will also be coming forward to
to the working group as well
thank you members um right okay moving
on to um agenda item seven which is the
medium term Financial strategy 23 24 to
2025 2026 on pages 39-46 so Misty Leslie
it's your night tonight so
over to you thank you chair uh the
median term of financial strategy
approved in February had a gap for the
next financial year of 1.3 million
pounds due to historically high levels
of inflation uh this was forecast to
increase
table two on page 41 details some of the
inflation assumptions and the total
inflationary cost is in table one on
page 40. the largest contributing
factors to the inflationary figure are
staff costs and the waste contract which
are the council's two biggest areas of
expenditure with the waste contract
linked to to inflation
staff inflation accounts for around half
the inflation figure next year as an
addition an additional five percent pay
award it is forecast dude I have to say
that that is uh provisional based on
current estimates and we also have the
additional 2.75 budgeted shortfall from
this financial year as well which we
need to catch up for with the budget in
next year there is also the incremental
pay increases in Pay points and a one
percent increase in pension
contributions that are required by the
pension fund now as well
however due to the council's a pension
fund deficit contribution and investment
income increases as a result of interest
rates
the forecast deficit for the next year
has in fact reduced to under 900 000
pounds an estimated pension fund deficit
contribution of 1.6 million was expected
to be paid next year based on the last
payment but following the tri-annual
valuation a contribution of 351
000 pounds will actually now be required
paragraph
7.1.1 on page 42 does provide further
details around the pension fund deficit
it's important to note that the forecast
is based on a do nothing scenario and it
does not take into account of any
savings increases to fees and charges or
new commercial income which would have a
cumulative effect over the years
there Still Remains a high level of
uncertainty including the local
government Finance settlement which is
due to be announced in December page
seven on page 40 provides further
information around the areas of
uncertainty
thank you
um uh now we've got two recommendations
to agree the reports but do members have
any questions beforehand
councilor stamp
um not so much questions Madam chair
um but um I'd like to ask um all the
directors
um because I'd take on board what cancer
siddles just said about looking after
our staff are we now assured that the
Staffing levels and the structure are in
the right place has it been reevaluated
since
um the transformation the transformation
was mentioned the other day
um about the possible whether it was
successful to saving the savings is what
we were hoping as a council
um and I would uh I'm sure the directors
are and have got some suggestions but
sometimes
um cancels like what we've got can be
top heavy and light on the actual
workers and the people who deliver the
services so can I have reassurance from
the directors and and their managers
underneath or whatever that they are
doing their best and we are looking
after our staff and we are actually
constantly constant reviewing our
services thank you madam chair thank you
Mr Holmes
Jim thank you
um yes I can give you some reassurance
members this evening so you recall back
in September Council looked at a report
on Service delivery itself and the
structuring service delivery so that is
very much around the managers and
directors looking at the service
provision and looking to see whether the
teams are structured correctly whether
we have the right resources in place so
that that work members approved for
Service delivery but also simply bring
back a report later this year on
planning and that will obviously do the
a similar thing and we are right now
looking at the structure pay levels
everything that's connected to to the
staff effectively and how we want to see
that um potentially structured to make
that a really successful service so that
work is is ongoing at this very moment
and a report will be coming back to
council by the end of the year
any other questions or can we note and
agree these reports
School agreed
thank you members okay moving on to
agendum item eight which is
discretionary fees and charges 23 24. on
pages 47 to 72 and that's Mr Leslie
again
the council applies an inflationary rate
to its fees and charges based on
August's RPI figure last year it was 3.2
percent uh and this year however it is
standing at 12.3 percent
that rate has been applied to the 2324
charges shown in appendix a where
applicable
the inflationary pressures facing the
council have been highlighted in the
previous report
given the high levels of inflation
appendix C model is the estimated impact
of income by varying the percentage
increase so members can see the impact
of that appendix B summarizes the fees
and charges that are due to change
it is noted that the council agreed to
keep the discount relating to the
wolfidge so this will remain but
inflation is proposed to be applied
foreign
thank you Council again Madam chair 3.5
the Promenade Car Park parking policies
to aim for overall maximum cost recovery
of the entire park
um is this and it says that a report's
going to come to council or SNR shortly
is this going to include a total revamp
and a re-look at the whole thing I mean
I think there were some discussions
about some sort of cameras coming in to
play most probably at a later date
um and is it going to coincide with the
much
awaited was it Promenade plan Promenade
Park management plan and because I I'm
really concerned that we're going to
look at things in piecemeal again rather
than look at the whole thing
um and and you know I can't remember
when it was due to come was it 2012 or
when it started 2016 project so I mean I
think we do need to actually start to
move some of these things forward
because I don't want it to be just let's
look at the review of The Promenade
parking there's parking everywhere thank
you Joe okay Mrs Green
thank you members um the intention is to
um in the uh first half of next next
year to look at car park and a full car
parking strategy not just for the prom
Park but actually across all of the car
Parks
um so that will look at
um sort of proposals for for increases
it will include consultation and it will
look at some things like whether or not
those car Parks should be designated as
a short stay long stay
provision of free car parking spaces so
it will cover you know the whole sort of
Gambit of of options for the car Parks
so the intention is to bring that to
that work to be carried out in the first
half of the new year and that will be
used to help inform a mid-year review of
the car parking
okay um thank you um no we got Council
again do you want to ask a question next
and then I'll go to counselor Fleming
yeah thank you chair um
yeah I think Council stands right is a
very good point and thanks Miss green
for clarifying that but it will would
should form part of the Promenade part
management plan strategy when it comes
together mine was just a um a query on
page number UH 60 of the appendix a when
on the council met on the 3rd of
November we did talk about fees and
charges on warfage and I watched the
tape back again today to make sure that
I wasn't going mad and what council
actually resolved it will go up by 10
and then the rate of inflation
thereafter and that's been 2020 to 23
that's been applied as the calculation
I've done makes the same but you can't
agree 23 24 because we don't know what
that figure is going to be yet so that's
going directly against the resolution of
Council on the third so I just want that
noted and that amended yeah
okay
we'll we'll note that thank you
again and also that be amended from the
this needs to be admitted for when we
vote on whether we accept these fees and
charges or not yeah I'll get the
directors to look into that after the
meeting um because obviously I can't say
now
um thank you and yeah you can sorry you
can we do respect you can you can admit
23 24 because you don't know what the
right of inflation is going to be in
there which was against the resolution
we need to see
Mr Nissi okay take it what would what we
do with the fees and charges obviously
set
um the rates for the next year based on
a inflationary figure that we know at
the time so obviously we don't know what
the inflation will be for the following
year and we obviously won't know until
we're into the following year so in
order to set the rates for inflation
before the first of April we have to use
a figure that we know so historically
we've used the August RPI figure to do
that so we need to set the fees and
charges by the first of April so that's
how how we do that is use a point in
time where we know the inflationary
figure because obviously we won't know
what inflation was until we get to the
end of that Financial year which
obviously will be too late by that time
just to answer your question it gives me
a methodology but doesn't give me the
clarity that I'm after because fees and
charges basically we could go I'm not
going to do this tonight because it's
not this is not the environment and the
place to do it but you know I'd like to
look in the detail and calculus of how
everything is in charge in everything
that the council does is calculated and
benchmarked and I'm concerned that if we
place something in here and this goes to
council and it gets agreed then that is
the charge yeah we need to be really
clear on this
um and caveat and say you know it could
because council did make that resolution
on the 3rd of November specific to this
one item well sorry I apologize two
items with car park as well so while I
accept the the explanation
um from the director of resources it
needs to be very clear and minuted that
that inflationary increase will be
applied at the time when we set again
yeah exactly that's something that we
can't do in this committee that's what I
meant by saying that but I mean that's
something that I'm sure you'll bring up
at Full Count as well
yeah
um right thank you councilor Fleming
thank you chair I just wanted to go back
to the car park strategy can I just ask
Miss green is that going to be an
in-house exercise or are we bringing in
Consultants thank you
it's likely we'll bring in some
additional helps a big big piece of work
for officers to do but officers will
certainly lead that review and there
will be engagement with members
businesses and the public
thank you
thank you oh sorry and then cancel the
channel council's little sorry can I
just come back yeah uh so can I just ask
when that will start and and have you
already sort of scoped out a company to
do this uh how far along the line are
you thank you
no it hasn't been scoped as yet
all right so we've got counselor said
it'll counselor Channel and then
councilor flukery against the siddle uh
thank you madam chairman uh so in in
terms of the inflationary increase uh
what figure are we getting for what was
it in August and is that what we're
going for in terms of these increases
yeah yeah to be very clear
um the RPI figure in August was 12.3
that figure has been applied to the fees
and charges in appendix a as as
previously stated but I think it's worth
flagging that as it stands the inflation
figure used is 12.3 and that is covering
the figure that would be approved
independix C there are various rates to
allow members to compare the difference
in income that different rates would
apply to so that's information appendix
C which is deemed to help with decision
making
all right
thank you counselor Channel
oh thank you madam chairman yes I'm
going to go back to the car parking I'm
afraid and again it is if the
inflationary rate is applied uh Mr this
is just explained that and I have
obviously read um appendix in I can see
the changes when you see the varying
um sort of application of degrees of um
the inflation rate which I think are
referred to at Council there'd be a
table showing members
um the differences that could be applied
I know it's a stupid question because we
largely do it with cards now but will
that result in the car park charges
actually being rounded up the right way
we won't have any like five P's coming
into the equation because I know when I
mentioned this before I was told that
the reason we couldn't do something
because it could make it difficult to
our machines but obviously now it's much
more applied for by cards that might
alleviate that but it's always but if
you have round figures I think so I
asked that question Also regarding
um the questions on the car parking
strategy and everything we did actually
have it one time and I have asked this
question before and my understanding was
it could be reconvened we had a car
parking task and finish working group
and that was made up of members and it
was members who became involved in
matters like this so I would very much
hope regarding the member engagement I
heard it was going to be largely officer
lead and then there'd be consultation
with members and businesses and what
have you I would have thought that we
need to reinvigorate that car parking
task and finish working group
um or whatever it was called because I
think that's quite important to have
members actually involved in the
formulation of any strategy going
forward for the longer term Madam
chairman and if I please may ask on the
pre-application process I have looked at
appendix in I'm aware of the fees and
charges can you assure me that under
12.3 percent should that be applied that
that will give full cost recovery
bearing in mind the pay increase is
coming regarding our officers that that
will result in full cost recovery for
pre-applications taking off as a
resource time and not be sort of
supplemented by any taxpayer money
coming from another budget so thank you
okay fancy I said right Mr Holmes I
think is going to answer some of the
questions
um yes thank you on car parking
um so yes I I agree I think it would be
helpful to reconvene the working group
with members and we've done that in the
past when we've looked at fees and
charges and I think that will be a very
sensible thing to do
um so we will be looking to to involve a
consultancy for this um piece of work to
support us and because obviously the
strategy will not just look at the fees
and charges look at where the car parks
are type of use for the car Parks
haven't got enough car parking so a
proper sort of review of our parking
provision so that that's the intention
and I think the working group will will
be reconvened to do that and obviously
that will then send its report back
okay thank you Ms Holmes and then with
the Mr Leslie for the I think Mrs
Wheatley
oh is it Mrs Wheatley I do oh she's
online on Mrs Wheatley could you come
and help answer the question on the
other ones that were raised by counselor
China please
thank you
okay uh right my question was obviously
I'm looking at appendix C I'm aware of
the other documents but I'm specifically
homing an appendixie and hearing Mr
Leslie say that currently it is intended
the 12.3 percent August inflation rate
be applied to our fees and charges my
interest is in pre-application process
and the charges obviously that involves
officer time regarding pre-application
meetings now I know currently we're only
dealing with certain elements in terms
of pre-application but do I want
assurances of is that that application
of that increase does in fact cover
total cost recovery for the time of our
officers in the times that they give
resource-wise to pre-application
inquiries and meetings Etc because with
staff incremental Rises and that's
lovely there are staff getting an
increase but on their pay which is right
bearing in mind as councilor siddle
referred to however I want to know that
we will make sure we have total cost
recovery and we're not actually having a
supplement coming from the general
taxpayers it should be perhaps those
developers that meet that charge thank
you
we calculate officer costs in terms of
the effort that is spent on providing
these Services
we haven't accounted for this financials
years increase because that was only
confirmed just recently but we will
review it again we tend to review it
every couple of years to make sure that
we are adjusting it up or down depending
on the amount of effort and time that
goes into providing that service so it
doesn't incorporate the increase for
this financial year but it's an exercise
that we will do for the next financial
year and we will address those fees if
we need to
okay uh thank you Miss sweetie I think
um Mr Leslie wants to come back and then
if he doesn't answer your question I'll
let you come back again I suspect you
might know where I'm coming from so I'll
let him know
I don't think it's worth pointing out
that obviously um we didn't know about
the confirmed pay increases but in terms
of the actual RPI increase of 12.3
percent
um that's been
um proposed matched against obviously
the pay award the backdated pay award
and the other inflationary pressures
around Staffing which I talked about the
12.3 percent
um will should cover that we've had a
constant that actually if you add up the
percentage increase in staff to 12.3
percent
um would cover cover that side and as
Mrs Wheatley has said we'll do a
recalculation of those just to check
that that is the case later on for 12.3
percent is obviously
um a
um a sufficient chunk of inflationary
increase that should cover the pressures
but we appreciate that work is still to
be done and to be confirmed
oh thank you madam chair that gives me
some assurances of course if we also had
bearing in mind we start from a case
where we're doing total cost recovery
and I'm not totally sure that we have
but hopefully we are I'll take on board
Mr Leslie says but I think that is my
well my fundamental wish that obviously
we ensure that we do have total cost
recovery and would that include
overheads
yeah on the basis that the um
current figure uh includes those
overheads that would obviously uh
increase the um charge the overheads um
even that uh in that increase as well so
the overall sum will increase by 12.3
percent
um but in terms of the overheads I think
I'll probably just have clarification
from Mrs Wheatley that that does include
uh relevant overheads as well but that's
something that we picked up as part of
the review too thank you
thank you Mrs Wheatley
yes I'm sorry
yes it into it all overhead so you'd be
doing too but we put them classes
backpack costs which you know relate to
the associated utilities and all of the
associated costs there thank you okay
lovely thank you thank you um Council
fluka and then councilor stamp yeah
thank you chairman
um I just you know bear in mind that we
are providing free overnight parking in
the car park outside can can miss green
assure me that maybe we will bring
forward a policy for that car park
sooner than the others
um there's even bits on social media now
from various trades people who are
saying it's a great place to leave your
van it's protected by CCTV the parking's
free and it seems to be free all day as
well
um you know at the end of the day we've
got to pay to resurface that car park
and replace the equipment so
um you know can you assure us that
you're going to bring that forward
separately
um given the amount of usage it's
currently having and tonight is no
exception that should be before we go to
Mrs Green I just thought I I thought
we'd raises the last meeting so it'd be
interesting to have an update uh now
this evening so Mrs Green
um so a couple of things remember so we
during covid there was a relaxation of
the use of the car park particularly as
it was used for the vaccination Center
however now we have returned it back to
full use and the car park is now being
used on a permit basis by staff so we
are starting to do enforcement work to
ensure that the car park is only
occupied by either people that have paid
or where there is a permit uh
to use it and that's permits for staff
and partners that are authorized to use
our car park so if you let me come back
chairman perhaps after the meeting my
screen you could circulate the
enforcement information so how many
tickets we've issued and what we've
recovered over the last three months I
think that would be useful to see that
we're actually dealing with this
properly because I suspect it's the same
vans that are there all the time maybe
they're paying a fixed penalty ticket
every day because it's that it's cheaper
to do that but clearly something isn't
quite right here and I appreciate that
you are looking at it though thank you
um is on the second part to the
questions we are currently looking at a
a formal new uh car parking Arrangement
and offering
um permits
um to purchase form members of the
public and for businesses so we're
actively working on that at the moment
I'm delighted that you took up my offer
thank you
I think I can't remember which paper is
in I know I've read that in one of these
papers about this car parking and the
car park being used yeah
okay thank you um councilor stamp that's
a quick one Madam chair who is on the
car parking group because I don't
remember it being on the um
yeah that's right so who's going to be
on it or will you send a thing around
please I believe it was I'm not sure it
was done at the last and so it'll have
to be done I believe because it went
into a sort of hibernation okay Mr
Dawson well I believe it's a task and
finish Group which by its nature is a
poor he's appointed to undertake the
task in hand for and until it's finished
so it's only appointed on a sort of
interim basis
um but I think it's an appointment of
counsel so so people go to council for
the group to be appointed
I mean does it have to be appointed by
Council because I'm just thinking it's
going to report back to this group isn't
it this group is going to report to
council I think it just sort of speed
things up because it would normally come
to this Council yeah well what we
discussing I think we could just do it
tonight it was also relating to the same
question
I actually think that it should be
um reporting to council because
obviously uh councilor Mays is the sep
rep so she would need to be on it in my
view I'd also like to be on it as the
county member my my inbox is I I get
many uh complaints about parking or
issues in the town
come back yeah thank you Mrs Wilson I do
feel it's a matter for the groups as
well to have a consideration quite
frankly on the that's normally I know
they're not politically balanced but
normally there's some discussions
I just normally have a discussion just
wanted to say I think that the previous
group was made up of
um members from different committees
rather than a single committee which is
why it would have been appointed by by
Council so yeah okay well I think we
need to make sure we go on the next
agenda at full Council because it is
important that we get to get this going
because if we can be claiming in for
enforcement we should be doing it
um okay right members oh God my iPad's
gone to sleep now
um I think there were two
recommendations
um little ones the detailed fees and
charges and set out an appendix a b
agreed a little two that the inflation
rate to apply to specific speeds and
charges are set out in appendix C be
agreed
members are you all in agreement
we're agreeing in this committee yes to
the council that's our recommendation to
the council yes
okay thank you everybody okay moving on
to agendum item nine which is the 2324
Capital project bids on pages 73 to 96
and it's Mr Leslie again
all right well table one on page 73
shows the six new projects that are
proposed for approval
appendix a provides the detail around
those
the two projects relating to Riverside
Park have had section 106 contributions
identified to fund these with the
remaining bids to be funded from Capital
receipts Reserve that'd be for any
questions
I'd always understood that the
total revamp of the century garden and
so on in front Park had 106 funding set
aside for it
so would that be
Mr Mr Holmes
I think Jim you're absolutely right
there is 106 funding available for the
part of the project this is very large
project in terms of replacing all the
play equipment and Landscaping as well
so this is to fund the top up that
budget effectively to give us enough to
cover the whole project itself but the
106 money is also available and will be
used as in connection with the project
okay thank you um councilor stamp thank
you madam chair so just to be clear is
the figures that we've got written down
here the figure that's coming out of our
capital budget or it's a mixture of both
and if it's a mixture of both hand which
is coming from 106 and how much is
coming out from the council the second
Point Madam chair is I think you're
really lucky having the sensory garden
being replaced and the things because
some of us don't even have one and we
don't even have a any send swings or
trampolines or anything in their
District I can't speak for cancer fluka
I don't know if he's got any in his
Parks but I know in um in Burnham on
Crash we don't have a trampoline we
don't have a swing to Coke to cater for
um send pupils and I think we're
actually being quite exclusive rather
than inclusive Madam chair so once I
note the repairs on the and grateful for
the ones because I'm always grateful for
anything to come to Burnham on Crouch
nowadays is I think we also also had to
look at spending some of that 106 money
and we've got plenty because we've had
loads of houses is built where I am and
I think we ought to be looking at
expanding it so instead of just
replacing Madam chair they oh I've got
to find the page if they forgive me the
one with the Mr Holmes might be able to
oh there we go page 91 the 45 000 and
the ones with the big
um what are they called great big wooden
Tire things where you swing and whatever
you do on them
um can we actually think about maybe
changing that and incorporating some
things for other people that we don't
cater for in our district or is it too
late please thank you Mr Holmes I'll
name that one at you um I don't believe
it's too late at all um Jeff for us to
be able to review that and we'll see 106
funding is available as a lump sum
normally what would happen is we would
look at the designs we would go out to
Tender and invite um proposals so I
think it would be helpful for us for us
to have a separate discussion around
this um so that when we actually get to
look at that 106 money it's money it's
how it's how it will be how it will be
spent um but yes so not too late
brilliant so could that be noted in the
minutes that Mr Holmes is going to have
a meeting with me about that specific
project please and the chairman I think
we'll be there during that meeting so um
yeah thank you I am being a bit
different but it really is important
that's open to all members if all
members have any items they'd wish to
raise for section 106 funding um going
forward we haven't we've only got a
finite budget
um but obviously you know know it is
there and I think everybody should get
an equal opportunity to apply for it
um councilor fluka and then councilor
shauncey thank you German
um yeah I mean
when you look at this you think well
there's a huge amount of money going
into modern town uh there's nothing
really going into uh into Burnham or
indeed southminster now we have two
parks in South Minster that are owned by
Malden District councilman I know that
Mr Holmes is working very closely with
myself to try and arrange a meeting with
um the the officers from Malden District
Council to see how we can deal with
those Parks because at the moment
um they're basically maintained by
volunteers now it may well be that those
volunteers at some time walk away which
means they're going to be a cost
implication to this Council but
we you know this Council financially is
in a very difficult position it doesn't
matter how you dress it up
um and when I look at things like the
replacement of The Galleon yeah the
Galleon is a great thing it's iconic I
suspect it's not zyconic as the Thames
barges uh but nevertheless it's
something that you know people in the
Pond Park have got used to but it's not
something that we've had forever and I
just find it really really hard to look
at that and say you know to see that
we're going to spend 220 000 pounds
worth of taxpayers money on what
substanceably
um a toy which I know that families in
southminster can't access because they
cannot afford to get to burn them so you
know maybe we should spread the love and
not spend all that money in Morden and
perhaps spend some of that money in some
of the other areas and and for those of
you that would have read the planning
application that went to
um Southeast area planning last last
night it was identified
by this Council that South minster is
one of the most depraved deprived you
knew I was going to get around the wrong
way one of the most deprived areas not
in the district but in Essex and I was
absolutely staggered to read that
statistic last night
um you know I think that's really really
hard and it's not something I'm sorry I
know we've got a you know health and
safety issue bubbling along in the
background but it's certainly not
something that I would support spending
all that money on one particular item
which isn't really available to the
whole district and and whilst I've got
your attention uh Mr Leslie as far as
these white van Replacements
um I mean it's extraordinary some of the
deals that are available now on lease
particularly with sort of pickup trucks
and everything else and one looks that
returns a money against
um you know the the capsule loss of the
asset
um you know you can get these vehicles
now I mean you can get a you can get a
23 sorry a full Transit 350 uh pick up
for about 400 pounds a month now on a
maintenance package so I I hope that
you'll look at those I mean I appreciate
your need for vehicles replacing because
they're very old looking at those but I
just hope you've done the due diligence
around leasing thank you okay well
firstly I'll go to thank you Council
again first I'll go to Mr Holmes and
then Mr Leslie
thank you chairman so with regard to
play equipment
um so essentially you you write a
Promenade part where you're fortunate in
receiving a government grant back in
2004 for uh Promenade Park and Riverside
Park and so both of those places
effectively date from that time so
officers maintain those play sites and
have done ever since the day where they
were installed um but a fairly strict
regime in terms of they're either fit
for purpose or they're closed
um and we we don't compromise at all on
those what the officers are saying now
is in that particular place I uh down in
prom Park which is the Galleon which is
heavily used a very popular facility
with our visitors and um you know where
they're coming from obviously it's not
just the district but coming out of
District so it is an attraction in
itself heavily heavily used all the year
round
um there really isn't a compromise in
terms of repairs are getting so
expensive now we're spending tens of
thousands of pounds replacing panels
having to inspect it more frequently
because we want to make sure it's safe
so it's I'm afraid it's all or nothing
if if we didn't fund this we would have
to Simply remove it now you could put a
cheaper Supply equipment in there but I
would
obviously be concerned of that because
it was always been a very high profile
dominant piece of equipment and very
popular with our visitors but I
appreciate it's a very expensive piece
of equipment too so all of these are not
effectively
um upgrades or improvements they are
relate to end of life
um and and I say I think the choices are
fairly Stark if we don't maintain them
and can't maintain them we should simply
remove them and and that's that's for
the safety reason to nothing else
austerity okay
um right Mr Leslie we did you have a
question there I think we did didn't we
the question was about considering the
best options
um for purchasing the vehicles so yes
that would be part of the consideration
that we're undertake I think we also
include that um consideration around the
climate um strategy as well and green
vehicles in that and if there are any
suitable Alternatives so that we do
consider um a couple of aspects around
that
okay and um Mrs buttons are mentioning
about we're also looking into green
options for the Vans um as well so I'll
speak for her there
um right as we've got a really long
agenda I will go around I've got
councilor stamp counselor Channel
councilor siddle but first we've got
cancer Swain
um followed by councilor shortnessy so
Council this way right thank you
chairman
um yes so I obviously must defend the
Galleon as Mr Holmes says it is a
crucial part and attraction
um in the
um Promenade Park
um I would certainly um we're welcome
seeing um uh some project uh come
forward for South Minister for
consideration
um taken overall I wonder for um
cultural purposes whether we could have
some figure
um for what um section 106 money plus
potential grants could be applied
against the total of these
um items of play equipment throughout
the district
okay it would be Mr Holmes
um I'd have to come back to members on
the 106
um allocations because as far as I
understand they are identified
um sometimes years in advance
um so I don't think it's you're able to
switch around so for instance you
couldn't take 106 funding and say let's
spend it on the Galleon instead but we
could do some analysis in terms of what
money is identified per site
um and set that out so I think that's
probably the the most straightforward
thing to do so you can see a bit like
we've identified at Burnham Crouch where
106 money was identified and could be
applied on one of our sites so I think
where where that is in existence we can
certainly highlight that as for grant
funding
um it is possible to apply for Grants
from time to times when they come up
um I would just obviously again
highlight the fact that we believe these
particular bits of Kit are coming
rapidly towards the end of life
um and it could take some time and no
guarantee of success to get funding in
the meantime we've got to keep them safe
and operating so that would be my only
caution run
okay uh thank you um right moving on to
councilor Sean the sea who hasn't spoken
yet so
over to you thank you um Madam chairman
um there is another playground that
needs an awful lot of work and that's
the West Malden Community
um play site
um which is um really almost falling
apart in places
um we do have some 106 money
um allocated and Mr Holmes is very aware
of this and um and he's also aware that
every time I see him almost
um I mention it um just so that he
doesn't forget
um thank you so much
thank you I'm right oh councilor
Thompson
uh thank you madam chairman uh I think
it's important that we investigate where
we can use six section 106 money
um and I'm sure Leander would be on this
cable we'll get it at doing that yeah
the prom Park is is our major attraction
in terms of the district and and it's
what people come to the district for or
know the district about I can really
understand that we do need to though
spread it across the whole of the
district and we don't do enough of that
at the moment my big concern though is
3.7 where it says that we haven't really
got any sizable Casper receipts and our
Capital reserves now are diminishing so
my question is when was the last time
this Council put money into the capital
Reserves when was the last time that we
put a sizable amount of money to to
replenish this
yes thank you so the the
um Capital receipts Reserve is
replenished when an asset is sold so
basically it ensures that Capital money
is ring fenced
um so it will require a sale of a
capital deficit I believe that the
sizable amount was built up due to this
the housing stock uh from that time and
that was obviously the large receipt
that went in there so it's been several
years since a sizable chunk um went in
there and that's absolutely right that
will only be replenished when that sale
of an asset
um takes place so once there is a
depletion in that capital reserve
funding for Capital will then move to
being a revenue implication and that's
where the budgeting in terms of the
future Capital program and the
medium-term financial strategy will come
increasingly important around that
okay councilor siddle so the the last
time really this Council and this this
to me is a neglect of the way that this
Council has been administered for a very
long time is the fact that really the
last time we put a large amount of money
was when we sold Council houses and and
it's not that is so short-term and one
of the things that we should have been
doing and we need to start doing as a
council is constantly building our
reserves up whenever we can and if we
are looking to yeah we've got the
Galleon thing which does need
maintaining we should be looking at how
do we at times put money aside light the
splash park we had to find money to do
that how we put money aside for rev when
we are ready to maintain these things
and that has been neglected by this
Council and by previous Administrations
we've been run by other administrations
so things could have been done when
other administrations were in charge
this is one thing I'll say but um Right
Moving on I've got counselor
um Chana next
um well thank you madam chairman
um I think we're all talking about the
Galleon so I will and Council swains
raise the points and I appreciate with
councilor fluke is coming from but the
Galleon I mean people come for a whole
day here and they do come I know from
speaking to people outside Suffolk they
come to our prom Park and I don't know
them I just happened to come
conversation and they use all the
facilities and they see it as you know
good value if you uh erode perhaps one
of the things in the prom part then we
may not get the level a visitor coming
that we did have and therefore car
parking and all the other aspects of the
kiosk could possibly suffer so as much
as I recognize it's a very large sum I
don't think we have any alternative
bearing in mind what I've read regarding
the report and the and in terms of the
existing Galleon so I think we need to
do that because I could see other issues
coming our way if we're not careful Mr
Holmes is right the only other option
would be probably total removal
regarding 106 one is I thought 106
monies had to be directly related to the
development coming in and the area of
that development we do not have sill now
I know it's a bit a bit different maybe
possibly with like Health Services but
it's again it's in that area like
Burnham on Crouch Development coming
there Health says what they need in the
area like doctors surgeries but I do
believe that you can't necessarily build
something in Malden and then say 1060s
could Supply something in Burnham or my
board and like councilor fluke I know it
mentioned about southminster I've
certainly got pockets of deprivation in
my Wards my parishes that I cover and
it's my Parish councils I'm sure with
every other member here who actually do
have they've put in place sites and
actually have equipment that they put in
and certainly
um through Essex I think well I
certainly didn't when I was the Essex
County Council I know councilor Fleming
has through locality funding we were
able to help with some improvements
there on projects regarding play sites
but perhaps this Council needs to look
at that maybe across the patch and see
where perhaps play provision or other
aspects need to be done a strategy I
don't know if that could be a done but
maybe we would have real mapping
exercise and see where our areas of
deprivation and need are and also
population regarding young children
because some Wards are more aging than
others so I just put that on the table
Madam chairman yeah Mr Holmes
thank you I will need to speak to
colleagues in planning policy but I do
believe there is a review as part of the
local plan that looks at play provision
as well so I will follow up and we can
respond to members of committee on how
that actually works
um so yes I think you're right we could
we have something we'll look at it on a
district level I think perhaps my point
perhaps I didn't make it very well where
we have play sites installed and we need
to maintain them when we're asking
funding because they are checked and
inspected it's not about this report is
not looking at um
new sites or putting sites in different
places in a way that's a different
discussion because if you want to see
more play provision across the district
then absolutely we could look at that my
point is where we've got them already we
need to maintain them and this is what
this this funding is asking you for
thank you uh right councilor Stan oh
actually
we must we must start moving on agenda
that's my understanding what I was
saying if you can't put one or six
monies for a play site in Malden oh
that's coming from something Immortal
and think you can do it to do up
something over in Burnham or something
or Supply something in Burnham I was
very well aware of I think where Mr
Holmes was coming Mr Holmes already okay
councilor stamp next chairman thank you
for coming lamy's come back um it would
have been better if we've got about two
meetings they said this one because
we're still going to be here at midnight
I feel but there you go
um yeah
um what I'd like to say though and I am
going to make the point I find it quite
ironic that the Galleon is going to cost
220 Grand yeah to replace and the
Burnham pontoon is still not actually
got its funding which is going to be
half the price but yet we re invested
how much was it cancer still in the
splash park can you remember I can't
last year so so you know come on this is
not yeah it's all right Mr don't know
where they're going to try and shut me
up it's different that it always seems
to go to Mall children and not burn them
on Crouch or somewhere else it's sorry
if I apologize I thought you was trying
to stop me speaking Mr Dodson
it isn't fair I can't believe that one
okay thank you chairman what I was going
to to say was that the the money for the
Pontoon was included in the
um UK SPF funding bid that was put in so
that should allocate the funding and
we're working hard to ensure that we can
bring that forward at the earliest
opportunity within that
let's go back to be clear that's
hopefully it was agreed it was going to
come out of reserves is it going to come
out reserves to bring It Forward it was
funding wasn't it
um in response to cancer stamp uh you
may remember the question was raised at
the corporate projects working group and
um I recently sent around an update in
relation to that that we had had
confirmation from the Department of
level and up homes and communities that
we could spend from Council reserves in
advance and then claim that the money in
the appropriate year for um from UK
share Prosperity fund we are still
waiting for the outcome of the
submission of that investment plan
unfortunately and so once we receive
that confirmation and obviously we'll
bring a relevant paper to to committee
to approve the use of those reserves in
advance of receiving the allocation in
the relevant year for UK share
Prosperity fund
all right
okay I mean I will allow you to come
back but it needs to be really quick
because otherwise I'm gonna draw this
through clothes we've got about two
minutes so I've got counselor flu
Courier okay very quickly then so I mean
I must admit I don't at this stage we
don't know whether we're going to get
this funding or not so I I find it
remiss that we haven't got the Pontoon
actually in one of these projects
because it's easier to take it out than
put it in later when we go to council
the other thing is Chairman I'm just a
bit concerned about what the
recommendation is
um you know we're going to vote for
these piecemeal as a recommendation a
big problem as a collective not peace
meal uh again chairman we spent 10 years
raising money in southminster to build a
skate park but it looks as though this
council is going to spend 120 000 pounds
of uh taxpayers money on completely
refurbishing the Escape Park in Malden
which again the children in Malden the
children in southminster can't get to
okay thank you uh councilor Fluker
um right so I've got
um Council phone but it has to be really
short because I'm going to get really
tough in a minute about closing this
thank you Chad I just like councilor
Shaughnessy I wanted to express my
disappointment that the West Malden
Community Center playground is not on
this list so I wanted an update of when
that is due for refurbishment and uh
your reference 106 monies are they
historic or are they linked to the
current uh sites around linebrook way
thank you
chairman I believe the historic amounts
of money and I believe West Malden is
like a forward plan I don't think it's
it was something like 23 24 before that
money was coming forward but I think the
simplest thing you need to do is to
identify all those play sites
um there's some funding that's mainly
available through 106's and circulated
to this committee and hopefully that
will give you give the answer all I can
assure you is if it we know that West
Malden is coming toward the end of life
but it is maintained
um had that money not been available
through 106 and it needed a replacement
you that's when you would have seen it
on this but I think knowing that there's
106 money coming I think that's why it's
not on the list for no other reason
um yeah they they have to be safe they
have to be maintained so in one way or
another we will be coming back to
members for funding at some point okay
members that counts the challenge is
your um question relate to the agenda
from the beginning just no just a point
of clarification were you arguing the UK
SPF money my understanding is we get
that it's the leveling up bid where we
put the bid in but the burn and pontoon
is under the UK which we know we're
getting but it comes in tranches now
regarding Malden's tranches it's how
they balance it going across and you get
the greater amount possibly a bit
further in and I think that's why you
can use your reserves you know you're
going to be getting it I think that's
where Miss Cable's coming from I hope
that might be the case though they're
now saying you know you're going to get
the money but if you want to spend
something and it might be greater than
the sum total you've got in let's say
the first tranche then you can do
because you can know you're going to get
something coming in year two or whatever
I think that's what the officer meant I
hope
so the point of clarity
I will allow you to your point of
clarity and Gemini I'd just like to
clarify with Mr Holmes that if we
increase the car parking by additional
five percent would that pay for the
Galleon thing
apologies
yes I think Kim I don't think we need to
answer that one yeah well I'll I'm sure
Mr Holmes will come back to you on that
one right okay members um we've got a
really long agenda so
um the recommendations are committee
reviews the project bid set out
Independence a in preparation to
recommend a 23-24 capital program at the
strategy resources committee on January
23 for approval by the council in 2023
so it's coming back before it goes to
council I'm sorry Mr Logan I'm not
taking any more questions on this there
are we um all in favor all agreed or not
no no and thank you for not letting me
speak although my hand was raised twice
you acknowledged me twice and you've
taken away again a democratic right to
raise Point uh as a mortal Ward member
um so I don't agree with this if and I
want that completely noted I want to
noted that I was not allowed to speak on
the agenda I am about a modern asset
thank you yeah would you like a recorded
vote on that do I have a second
absolutely thank you do I have a second
for a recorded vote
okay right
um
yeah
for all of them um Tara could you
organize the recorded vote please
[Music]
for the recommendations four
against
it
against
four
against
Swain
four
right four
well thank you I'm not going to get
involved in any service failure or
anything like that so far thank you
and um
thank you yeah and uh and Council like
I'm just say that I'm sorry that I um I
didn't uh you know I used to it
previously but um normally members do
start waving their hand when we get um
close to finish twice my points are
noted I'm not going to take any further
okay okay right uh moving on so we have
um agenda item
um 10 which is the rural settlements
list
um there was one there was one query
raised to me
um by a member and that was why we have
no fanbridge split into North and South
where some of the districts have split
North and South
does anybody know why this is
yeah this is
um a very historical list that's been uh
hit around for a number of years which
we've been
um using to determine the rural
settlement my understanding is that it
works with the planners to identify uh
relevant settlements and where they
perhaps could be split so although we
don't have someone here from the
operational knowledge of the side of it
but my understanding would be that
that's been mapped out with the planning
of it and notified as sort of a separate
settlements but if if that's something
that the committee will be interested in
I'm happy to get someone who's uh
you'll be able to give sort of a
detailed answer
um
thank you chair thank you Mr Leslie I
haven't sat on this committee for a
couple of years now so I that's the
first time I've seen North and South
fanbridge so I I understand why we have
the list it's for Rural rate relief so
I've just I'm just puzzled as to why
fanbridge population maybe four four
five hundred people tops is separated
into two settlements I just I don't
understand that the same for all Thorne
I don't understand that
so I suppose my question is does that
influence planning policy in any way
could I have your Assurance no it
doesn't no this is purely for our rural
settlement list and purely to help
identify those raw businesses which can
access uh rural rate relief thank you
okay I've got councilor fluka um Council
Fleming's mentioned author and uh so I
think it's only right and probably I
mentioned my friends World great
Tottenham because that's North and South
as well yeah as is North North fanbridge
weird yes councilor siddle uh well I
think it's really important that we do
have this separation great Totten North
and great Tottenham South are very they
although it's one Parish are very
different entities uh and great
Tottenham North is far more rural than
greater Tottenham South so I think it is
important yeah from my point of view and
my ward that we keep this distinction
members um right so um do we all agree
to approve this recommendation
agreed okay thank you members okay
moving on to a gendum item 11 which is
the Malden District Council disabled
facilities Grant policy in
2022-2025 which I have for Mr dugud
foreign
policy
2022-23 which outlines the approach of
the council's private sector housing
officers in relation to the dispensation
of the better care fund for the purposes
of delivering grants for disabled
adaptations in the district
the better care fund navigates monies
for purpose of providing disabled
facilities grants also known as dfgs
for the financial year of 2223 modern
District Council was given 612
132 pounds to fund grants associated
with disabled facilities and adaptations
the council is required to provide
disabled facilities grants under the
housing grants construction and
regeneration Act of 1996.
the ACT explicitly covers the provision
of mandatory disabled facility grants
upon receipt of an occupational
therapist recommendation
the Malden DFG policy seeks to set out
the types of Grant assistance available
up to a maximum of thirty thousand the
eligibility criteria for obtaining a
grant
guidance on making Grant applications
and the service standards to be expected
as such the DFG policy thinks to
formalize the processes involved in the
dispensation of the better care Fund in
line with the housing grants
construction and regeneration Act of
1996.
most afford to build our DFG specialist
is on hand this evening to answer any
random questions thank you
okay members
okay councilor stamp
um thank you madam chair
um when I was reading the paper I
actually just put at the top advertising
because a lot of people most probably
don't know about it but are pleased to
note I've just put it in the search
engine for mold and it actually comes up
which is an absolute credit because
sometimes you put things in there and
nothing comes up so I agree with it
thank you that's good report okay thank
you and cancel it again
thank you for the noticing chair hi I'm
so pleased
um it's a really good report it's an
excellent piece of work yeah thank you
yeah I agreed um so so we um agree the
recommendation yeah okay well done
members okay thank you um right agenda
item 12 which is a supplementary
estimate request on pages 119 to 122
which is Mr Holmes I believe
thank you
um members uh yes this report before you
this evening asked for an additional sum
of money to manage the council's tree
stock background to this is that uh the
council commissioned Essex County
councils for its place Services team to
survey all of the council's trees on all
of its land stocks and they made them
series of recommendations uh for tree
Improvement Works um over a period of
time some of those Works have been
undertaken um 3.2 details of work
commenced um some of 14.5 000 was spent
on the most urgent works but there's
still a considerable amount of work to
do
um this report sets out the works that
would need to be done and the funding
that would need to be to cover it now we
would use Place services to give the
expertise but the actual Works
themselves would be carried out through
a tender process and suitable
contractors would undertake the work so
there is a revenue budget each year for
for tree maintenance and following
winter storms or any defects that appear
with trees but this effectively loses a
backlog and when we need to clear this
backlog to ensure that the tree stock is
in a fit State going forward it's
regrettable that we need to ask for this
a sum of money but unfortunately that
represents where we are with the the
tree stock at this this moment in time
thank you okay thank you uh councilor
fluke and then kiss the stamp well I
think chairman if you look at
implications Roman uh four I think it
sums up uh exactly where we are
financially
um
you know I know we haven't had a tree
officer for quite some time uh but I'm
I'm absolutely staggered at some of the
figures in here and what I'd like to be
assured by
um Mr Holmes is through you chairman is
that throughout the the district we have
a lot of a boy cultural companies all of
whom are properly qualified and there
has been a concern from some of them uh
over how difficult it is to get onto the
tender list to carry out works for this
Council even if you go through the I
think the Essex procurement Hub it's
very very difficult to do so
um and my feeling is is that we should
whatever possible use them and perhaps
we should find a way of encourage them
to register with the Hub or at least
support them to do so and this is
something that comes from that industry
sector quite a lot
um I don't know how you're going to pay
for this
foreign
yes I can speak to colleagues in our
procurement team to see how contractors
how easy it is for contractors to get
onto that list if there's any
improvements we can make to that and
obviously in talking to place services
in terms of overseeing that that process
we can we can express that view as well
so I'm sure we'll do everything we can
to open the uh the process so
contractors can bid for this work itself
um I I think as I said before we have
responsibilities as landowners tree
stock is is our tree stock and we do
know what needs to be done to them it is
a matter of cost unfortunately now and
having the contractors out to to
undertake the work so
um we will obviously look at the budget
we've asked Place services to go back
and review that assessment if we can
make a saving obviously we will I can't
guarantee that and I can't even
guarantee that so there's more work to
do
um over the summer of this year where
obviously trees have been distressed
because of drought conditions but at the
moment this is our best estimate of the
works and this is where we're asking
members for your support
I
I
sorry can I come back are you kind of
it's quick nope nobody likes the nuclear
option they're dealing with trees but we
can't afford to maintain these going
forward and you know we we need to make
some big decisions here and and you know
giving huge amounts of money to place
Services when I believe we could have
done this in house with our own tree
consultant I mean I I don't know how
many I don't even know how many trees
we're talking about
um I suspect it's probably about 150
maybe it's in there somewhere but you
know I I think we should do this on a
piecemeal basis using local companies
who are quite adequate to do this type
of work
so thank you his home so I have so I do
agree with those sentiments we do have a
lot of contractors who you would think
would be cheaper but so to be clear
Place Services 12 000 pounds for them to
oversee this work um so it's a hundred
thousand pounds for the actual Works
themselves which would be subject to
competitive temper and I heard what you
said about trying to use local
contractors so this isn't paying as it's
County Council plate Services the whole
amount of money this is to ask them to
oversee the work
um and to supervise that work and us to
get competitive prices for the work
itself so um that's that's what I could
so for clarity Gemini I think it is
important then so the 12 000 pounds that
we're paying Essex County Council places
Services
includes not only the survey that
they've already carried out but also
them supervising the work is that
correct that's correct that's my
understanding that with supervised that
work under their expertise um the work
carried out by contractors that will all
be within the twelve thousand pounds
that is my understanding chairman and
for clarity uh over 265 trees have been
identified for work foreign
thank you madam chair
um a Burnham Town Council we've also
done we did ours a few years ago
actually three years ago to Regina and
renewing it again and we're a bit late
at modern District to actually bringing
this in line so I actually welcome the
work that's been done I think it is a
necessity I totally agree with councilor
Luca though um that we I'm sure we've
tried to use local because there's loads
of them about you and you have to see
them all over I don't agree with him
with chopping them down though Madam
chair because it goes against everything
that we're actually doing in our climate
strategy so I actually welcomed the
report and I thank it for that it's been
done so comprehensively okay thank you
and councilor Channel
um thank you madam chair well I'm a
great supporter of trees and I agree
with Council stamp I mean they're in
intrinsic to our environmental
improvements and I mean that isn't the
queen wants everyone to plant a tree and
we know there's the Essex Forest
initiative and everything and we're
getting on board with that well I would
say that I do have um we can see where
Council of Luke is coming from because
when I saw the figure of the trick
number of trees I did for very good
reasons have to have six trees removed
last year and I know the cost that I
paid in taking Teresa and then of course
there's other works you might have to do
like prune back which is totally a much
cheaper option actually than having a
full grown tree so I worked out what my
six trees cost plus the pruning works
and actually I had quite a significant
amount left over from
um what's being quoted here so I I would
just think what might be helpful with
reports like this so we get a bit of a
detail knowing what the what the works
might be um that are required and I
noticed there's also a contingency so
I'm I'm being mindful that I think
rather than I need to get the 112k we
could see actually being 130k as
mentioned in a paragraph within the
report but trees are important
um to me and if you cut trees down um in
fact there's people hanging from
hammocks now in trees for a particular
oak tree that's got to be removed for
development not in our in our district
um so they are but I do think the cost
um does sound quite high but it may be
because we haven't got the detail of the
works that will be applied thank you
madam German yeah I agree entirely and
personally we've planted over a thousand
trees
um in the last two years and right
cancer
so in terms of this it seems like again
it's one of these things that we've
we've neglected and all of a sudden
we've got a big Bill uh it is is this
something that in terms of
um you know the the service that Essex
County Council is providing is this
something rather than employing a tree
officer at you know 40 000 pounds with
all the additional costs is that
something that longer term we can now go
into a shared service and a shared
agreement and making sure that this is
done every year so we're keeping control
of our our Boreal assets
Miss times yeah I think there's two two
aspects there obviously there is a tree
officer and that tree officer also
provides advice to town and Parish
councils and the council itself and
planning applications so that there's
that side of the work there's the
council's parks team itself which can do
limited amounts of um maintenance
directly itself and it also engages
contractors so um absolutely There's an
opportunity to work in a different way
going forward
um we are looking
um at a few Innovations around GIS
mapping around trees record-keeping
around trees to make sure we do have
that forward plan and a Ford view of our
tree stock so this you know is
effectively going to bring us bang up
today and then going forward we should
be able to manage that on a sort of a
rolling plan and I would like that to
see the expenditure rolled and I think
we have a not a huge summer each year
but it's probably 30 plus 30 000 plus a
year for dealing with trees if that is
used on a rolling basis
um but this is a backlog effectively
which needs to be dealt with now she
missed homes if I might come in there
and if we have a entry officer that we
employ
um why are we paying Police Services to
oversee the work because surely it would
be no problem for them to come out and
oversee the work that's being done
um within their normal duties
um chairman my understanding is because
of the scale of the work and if members
were mine just to give this budget then
obviously this would be done as quickly
as possible now Place services are
obviously part of Essex County Council
they provide that agricultural advice to
the council in any case for other
services so the view is that we should
be using Place services to have that
oversight get this backlog dealt with
and then obviously we can look at moving
forward and it may well be our own
contracted tree officer and maybe how to
manage that going forward but I think
just because of the scale of the work
now we feel it should be separated
but I'm sorry why hasn't he been
managing it as part of his duties anyway
we have a tree officer why have we
suddenly got this big backlog of work
when surely it could have been dealt
with I mean within his normal duties
when he's out and about pop into it and
and Survey each part it's not Jim it's
not the tree officer that either
suggests hasn't done this work I would
suggest that it's it should be carried
out through the operations team of the
the council and it hasn't clearly got
that forward plan
um I'm being completely honest that's I
think what's missing here
um it needs that floor plan we can see
that now so the tree officer does
support us he does go out he does advise
on trees this this is about a backlog
and using a contractor to help us
through that back look
okay on yeah okay um all right can't
we've got to keep this really short
because we have still got quite a bit to
get to the agenda Council flaming and
Council fluke could be gonna be really
really thank you German
um all right we'll do counselor
all right how's the blooming again thank
you chair I'm just going back to what Mr
Holmes said about forward plan um surely
it's what the insurers say I'm not sure
what what they've said to you about the
trees but I know that we're told that we
have to map all of our trees
um and you know to make sure that there
is a plan to keep everyone safe thank
you
okay okay
well I don't think it's uh you know I
don't think it's any secret that the
council's uh tree consultant is uh
non-somiciled in this country I just
wondered if Mr Holmes
um you know if we had somebody who was
in this country
um whether or not we'd be better placed
to perhaps deal with some of these
projects because you know we we have had
issues and I know Mr Holmes aware of
them thank you
Mr Holmes
chairman I would simply say that we've
reached out to place Services knowing to
have their skills and the capability to
do the large-scale survey for us and
they're also able to provide the
supervision of The Works um so that's
the reason we went to place Services
initially
uh thank you madam chairman
um trees should be inspected every three
years actually
um and then you don't you know build up
any problems I may ask if this work is
all proposed to be done this sort of
winter or some held over to next year
please
thank you
so I don't have a time scale for the
work it's over 250 trees that need work
obviously they'll be prioritized in
terms of the urgency of the work so
there'll be a program once we've engaged
with with the place Services I'm sure
that will be mapped out I'll be happy to
share that with members so they know the
order of the works that we've done
okay last week is councilor Swain so
councilor Swain and then we'll go for
vote the um the cost involved in this is
is not the the monitoring survey it's in
doing the work
um and I I think I agree with councilor
fluka per tree you know four to five
hundred pounds it seems to me
um uh too high quite expensive and if we
use Place Services we rely on them to
get
um uh the cheap the best quotes to do
the job and not just put it out to one
contractor to do the law I think it's
been covered with Mr Holmes yeah
absolutely we'll be through competition
um yeah that is our estimate we'd
obviously always try to improve the
estimate so it will be competitive bid
for the actual work itself and it may be
broken into Lots I think you know with
the scale it works isn't it probably
more than one contractor to be honest so
but that's something we'd obviously look
at to get best value okay right members
um so the recommendations are a little
one that are supplementary estimator the
sum of 112 000 is provided to fund the
Urgent tree Works identified broken down
into two elements as follows related
County Council Place services are
engaged to oversee all the works on
behalf of the council the cost of twelve
thousand pounds management
on the Essex County Council Police
Services costs of engaging with the
contractors for the tree works for the
cost of a hundred thousand
and little two that a further sum of 18
000 provided as a contingency sum to
cover unexpected costs associated in
undertaking the work identified in
little one above the members are we all
agreed with this are an agreement with
this
agreed okay thank you members
um moving on to agenda item 13 events
and Concession strategy 23-28 on pages
123 to 136. I'm not sure who's taking
this Mr butcher okay okay sorry Mr
Johnson I'd like to come in first thank
you
thank you I will hand over to Mr butcher
very very briefly I just wanted to to
briefly introduce the paper and sort of
emphasize the importance of this
strategy we have some wonderful assets
um within the district
um that have traditionally for numerous
years been used for events and it's
really important that we put in place
this this strategy that sets out how we
balance the events with protecting those
assets and delivering the commercial and
corporate corporate strategy but I'll
hand over to Mr butcher to set out in in
more detail thank you
thank you chair good evening members
yeah the the council is always welcomed
and valued temporary concessions and
events that support our local businesses
and ensure that we've got a diverse
vibrant and cultural attractions uh
coming to the district for our residents
and visitors to enjoy
this strategy recognized our Ambitions
as a council and is aligned with a
number of our strategies including our
commercial approach
it understands the need for
environmentally sensitive development to
make sure these assets are enhanced and
involved in a way so they can be enjoyed
by both the current and future
Generations
historically events within the district
have always been incredibly successful
and this strategy looks to build on on
that success and looks to adopt a more
proactive and forward-thinking approach
to seek New Opportunities across its
estate that meet the council's Strategic
objectives
and offer a wide range of choice for
both events and concessions within our
parks and Open Spaces
I think this strategy will help inform
the prom part management plan by giving
greater Clarity on what types of events
and concessions and the frequency they
will be permissible within our parks and
Open Spaces
and once the strategy is adopted a
delivery plan will follow and an annual
plan for any significant events of size
and and significant concessions will be
cascaded to members via this committee
officers will look to continue to work
diligently and listen to feedback from a
wide range of stakeholders during the
planning process each each annual
process as we look to build trust and
positive relationships throughout
thank you chair thank you members
councilor stem
um yes thank you madam chair
um I actually read it and I thought it
was actually really good the only
comment I would make and I was pleased
you answered it further on in the report
when I was reading I got my page one to
it and I put and listen because it looks
very good you read it but you must
listen to the residents as well when you
get the feedback and also if you can
consult as much as you can with Ward
members
um where you're actually going to hold
those events and because it's us who get
the comments all the time afterwards I'm
not saying don't do it because I think
it's really good and thank you very much
for doing it it's about time I don't
mean that naughtily but you know what to
me it's really good and I think we need
to adopt it so thank you very much
councilor Swain and then councilor flu
because I counselor say yes thank you
madam chairman uh so I would like to
make an amendment to this report and
it's on page 132 on the third paragraph
and that's about exceptional
circumstances and I think the opposition
Lee leader should also be included in
any discussions if there is an impromptu
event that comes up because this will
secure a cross-party working both now
and in the future
I'll second that
okay
um so I'll take a vote on this now and
then before we vote on the final um
thing so because I'm gonna come back to
you once we voted so do we all um like
to see this Amendment added to the final
recommendation
okay right okay so we will add that into
the recommendation at the end so we'll
do the recommendation with that as
Amendment as um suggested by um
councilor siddle okay um right so we
have got
um
councilor fluka Council again who else
would cancel us so I can cancel fluka
and then cancel again okay councilor
Swain
thank you chairman
um yes I have several points firstly
under the aims for the concessions
um I think there are two things which we
should say we do not want in the in park
one is the use of petrol or diesel
generators or engines and to say they
will not be allowed
and electronically produced music will
not be allowed for concessions
this is not applied to the main events
but to individual concessions that
shouldn't be electronically reproduced
um
music
on page 133
working with residents I think
organizations should be required to um
liaise with with local residents not
just encouraged
um
and the times for there are times put
for operations but no no nothing said
about
time limits on setup and set down which
we know from past events with the big
events has gone on in well into the late
evening night so I don't know how that
could be phased but it clearly there
needs to be some control on the setup
set down times
and lastly
um
stages for larger events
should be cited
um with
the welfare of local residents in mind
okay I
I've got all those um I think
environmental health covers things like
noise and generators I don't think
that's down to us to necessarily set
that but I'm sure Mr butcher will assist
yes thank you chair yes I think with um
with the diesel and petrol and
electronic music for concessions I think
at this moment in time we'd like to
review each um proposition on its own
merits and I wouldn't like to Discount
anything at this stage
um with with temporary concessions such
as an ice cream van I can understand the
rationale for not wanting to have diesel
there but that's uh eighteen thousand
pound a year contract to the council so
it's um we will look at Greener
Alternatives
um but it's not something I'd I could
necessarily agree to or would want to
put in place right now I think working
with local residents whenever we have
major events we always do engage with
local residents and uh and the owners
will be on the event organizer to do
that uh Cascade of information and
engage with local residents so that is
happening and I think there needs to be
a recognition I think I've got that in
the strategy that not everything is
going to be liked by everyone but that's
an accepted risk
um there will always be a handful of
people who do um want or or um support a
local event but we we do have the
thousands of visitors that do come and
support and enjoy those days out
um the setup and takedown of events and
stages yes you're absolutely right
um 2021 there was an incident we've
learned from that and it won't be
happening again we have that written
into all the terms and conditions to
ensure uh that there will be no uh setup
or takedown outside of certain hours
uh thank you okay
um
just briefly I I think we do really need
to try and avoid having an ice cream van
and I I know it's very profitable but um
it's pumping out um fumes throughout the
day right next to the play area and this
just doesn't seem to be
um acceptable these days
I think we'll we'll note that and I
think Mr Butch will perhaps we can
perhaps we can ask them if they'd
consider using other matters but I don't
think anything's really come ahead yet
that replaces diesel but I think by 2030
we'll see something for certain
could be battery operated for this yeah
when when they're good enough that we
can use them uh migrate entirely I mean
I've got an electric car so I'm all for
electric
right councilor fluka yeah thank you
Gemini I sort of I'm on agenda item 14
so I'll give away
okay right before before we take this to
the vote
um I think I've also like that's a good
wave
um
um it's a good piece of work it's just a
tad premature in my opinion I think look
what we need to do is we've got
the concession paper coming up to
planning Central area planning next next
week I think it is so that's going to be
Revisited now Mr dodson's looking a bit
strange there so is there anything
worrying yeah that you wanna
yeah I I'm
I'm waiting to hear all of your your
comments but this is a strategy not not
a planning document so so that that was
what perturbed me but I'll wait to hear
what you say counselor
thank you uh director because I hadn't
finished so yes it's uh it's amazing
isn't it um body language is a is a
strange thing
um
it's a strategy but what informs a
strategy
so we need to look at a policy and plans
so plans will inform what you do with
your strategy your strategies your
vision and how you actually achieve your
plan so I'm thinking from this there's a
couple of things that we I don't think
it should be thrown out at all I think
it should just be deferred until we look
at the prom Promenade Park management
plan
which is been debated quite considerably
um if we if we don't
then we could be in Jeopardy of not
having enough information from a
management plan to actually help inform
the strategy to be able to go forward
and I think that counts the Swain's
actually raised a couple of really minor
points we've we councils declared a
climate emergency we've we've said in
this chamber tonight we put money over
the environment
eighteen thousand pound a year for an
ice cream van great
but hang on if we have a strategy on the
prom Park management plan part of that
management plan is how we could look at
actually getting concessions on there
that maybe could actually generate
slightly more of a Revenue income for us
um but we haven't done that work yet so
once we've done that work we can link it
into this document and have the strategy
and then we can actually go and launch
that because I hear an awful lot about
the visitor offering we need visited
pounds to come in but we've also got to
think very carefully for the local
people for which the asset was left to
the to our care as well so the Borough
Council so what I think is a good piece
of work there's a lot of stuff in there
there is some real core aspects but I
think the sensible thing to do is we did
defer it until we get the problem Mark
management plan which has come part
early part of 2023 and then we can link
into this
thank you okay um thank you for that um
I don't think I need this coming so I
think it's been covered um right okay so
it now comes to I think we'll call this
to a close and um at the recommendation
is that the event strategy
2023-2028 appendix one be approved
um all those if you Tara can we have
uh with the amendment uh by councilor
siddle yeah we Council siddle's
Amendment
um right
yes I have to be second if Adam chairman
I'll second count okay cancer Tanner has
seconded the proposal by councilor
siddle
um right would you like I take it counts
like and you want to recorded vote yeah
okay Tara can we have a recorded vote
please
please
four
thank you uh councilors Mrs Fleming for
um
yes
cancer Lagoon
against please
thank you Council Shaughnessy
four but with the reservations about
fumes near children
thank you Council fiddle
four
oh
chairman councilor staff because Council
lager made some really good points
sorry just give me a sec okay
um I'm gonna support it for
you
four
four
councilor right for
eign
thank you Tara okay moving on to a
gender item 14 which is the rural
England Prosperity fund uh on pages 137
to 140. I've got this for Mr Dawson I
presume it's Miss cable
service cable Mrs cable or do you want
to yeah okay thank you chairman if
you're happy I've got a short
presentation to share with members so
I'll quickly join you at the top desk
okay
that's right it's safe
oh sorry
thank you chairman thank you members
the ruraling the prosperity fund is a
rural specific Top-Up to the UK share
Prosperity fund which is part of the
government's leveling up white paper
members will recall from the July
committee the council's approach to the
UK share Prosperity fund was agreed and
the investment plan submitted by the
first of August deadline
as advised previously in this meeting
we're still awaiting the outcome of the
submission but just to confirm
um it's not a competitive bid process as
with the leveling up fund is an
allocation but we still need to do the
due diligence for the investment plan to
be approved
the rural England Prosperity fund will
provide Capital funding for projects
aimed at small businesses and Community
infrastructure to help improve
productivity and strengthen the rural
economy and communities in essence it
will act as a capital Grant fund for us
to distribute to external parties via a
robust application and assessment
process
the fund was launched on the 3rd of
September and I'd like to advise members
that we were completely unaware that
this Edition Top-Up would be forthcoming
as no reference had been made to it in
any previous paperwork by the leveling
up fund or by the UK share disparity
fund guidance
during September and October we've
worked with rural partners and
stakeholders to gather evidence to
support the identification of the
interventions which could be supported
and currently we'll be refining our
addendum investment plan ready for
submission by the 30th of November
foreign
of the funds will be allocated to year
one which is identified as 2022 sorry
2023 2024 and the remaining 75 in year
two this has not been confirmed in the
guidance but only verbally by death
threaten the local Authority webinars
attended officers have chased defra on
more than one occasion for the
outstanding frequently asked questions
from these webinars but have simply been
advised that will they will be issued in
due course and to put it into context
those webinars are attended seven weeks
ago
officers will utilize the council's
nominated UK share Prosperity fund
partnership group one Malden District to
develop and inform our investment plan
in addition we have of course consulted
rural stakeholders and representatives
such as the Royal Community Council of
Essex National Union of farmers South
East local Enterprise partnership and
the countryland and Business Association
we've also been working through our key
themes which have been identified in our
existing strategies to enable to Target
the funding appropriately
and that's the end of the presentation
okay
um members thank you for that Miss cable
um councilor fluka
actually I'm interested
I'm going to declare any interest there
is no public speaking uh
which concludes me from speaking to my
own world and my own constituents and
stuff and stuff so Chapman I'm going to
leave the room
on the other standing that I hope a
member will ask a question on my other
half but I'm afraid this is where we are
if we have problems and I can't say I
specifically people agree with it being
applied under these so expenses naked
that's the stand post a little bit about
that stuff
don't worry
it's nothing serious we're all now
wondering what it is thank you Council
because you know that counselor flu
because
um leaving the chamber
um right so members
um to ask any questions
cancel the stamp
would you like me to read counselor it's
nothing innocuous I don't think I'm
breaking any rules so it just says
yesterday southminster Parish Council
was granted planning permission for a
new community center and sports Pavilion
wood officers agreed to meet with
councilor Fluker the ward member to
discuss this exciting and worthwhile
Community project Madam chair
I I don't see there's an issue surely
members would uh directors would agree
to meet with a ward member or is that
not allowed
just left the chamber but ass yeah okay
thank you of course give me some Mr
Holmes thank you okay The Identical work
counselor fluka back into the uh chamber
okay uh councilor
um
can you go outside again please Council
fluka can you leave the chamber again to
please because councilor channel would
like to raise the questions
thank you
okay counselor Channel
thank you madam chairman I think I'd
worked out what it was actually when
councilor fluka said that because there
wasn't Southeast last night and it stood
with the Community Hall and the
community facilities that are being
built what I would say is um obviously
bearing in mind this is across the whole
District 430
000 I mean there may be other schemes as
well so I would hope there might be some
way
um that this will be how do I put it
apportioned or whatever I don't know
when we get that money in a strata of
like maximum bids possible or however it
works or what might be a given because
obviously you're doing the work at the
moment and therefore I think there could
be other parishes or you know the
farmers farming community and others
that may see this it reminds me of it
the leader program or I think that's
what it's based on which was previous
yeah and you need um what we had to do
there was sort of have a quitability
across it and work out to get the
maximum benefit across the whole area so
that's all I would say that's just to
come I I consumer Council of flickers
coming from and that's fine but I think
there might be others as well that have
ongoing projects apart from other
aspects voluntary service yeah Etc thank
you absolutely I can't imagine that any
one one company or one idea is going to
get all the funding it's going to be
shared but I'll go into Miss cable I'll
explain it better than I can thank you
chair thanks thank you councilor and you
are correct this this is program is
modeled on the previous leader program
um which was European funding and I'm
not going to attempt to remember what
leader stood for because
um I believe it was French and my French
isn't that good
um but you're correct uh it is a capital
Grant fund we are looking at minimum and
maximum
um Grant uh levels that's to ensure that
that the money can benefit the community
as best as possible
um in terms of projects that are
supported
um the identified funding for year one
which is 2023 2024 is just over 107 000
pounds and the identified funding for
2024 2025 is just over 322 000 pounds
and when we talk about capital projects
they tend to be quite functional intense
and so what we would like to see is is a
maximum Grant level to ensure that
spread is evenly across the district
and I imagine it's going to be a very
strict criteria for what gets funding
and what doesn't it's not going to be a
yes directors decide
um right okay if we'd like to invite
counselor fluka back in and then I have
um
hold on a minute the councilor Swain is
yours on the same thing no the issue is
whether the fund would be applicable for
um any projects that have started or
underway in any sense
foreign
we don't actually receive the funding
until the first of April
um and it's not been advised that this
funding can be used to cover Spenser
they've been completed in arrays
um as it's a capital fund we're going to
need to be quite stringent
um in terms of the the performance in
the governance of the projects and so
our understanding currently is that it
cannot be used
um in in advance of receiving however as
I stated we're still waiting for those
um frequently asked questions from defra
I'm very disappointed that those have
not been provided to local authorities
in the past seven weeks bearing in one
we have 20 days to submit this
investment plan
and that has been expressed to to the
Department
I'd just like to come here and say that
we've been very lucky to have officers
like Miss cable who have got onto this
straight away and got some funding that
otherwise we wouldn't have got because
it's amazing that you turned that around
in 20 days until you have all the other
funding
um right cast channel is it related to
yes it's just something the officers
just said I mean I'm hearing about
sorry madam chairman I'm hearing about
the delays
um regarding obviously defra and the
officers made it quite clear very
disappointed not to observe frequently
asked questions and of course blowing
your mind the time frame for when this
bid has to be put in we're dealing now
with a very very short time before that
bid needs to go in therefore um I would
have a proposal Madam chairman should it
not be perhaps unforgive me for putting
myself forward if perhaps with the
director and the leader that we do
actually make an approach to defra to
see if we can perhaps get these
frequently asked questions or back up
what the officer's done it might just
help um get those out a bit quicker and
Mark on the other hand it might not I
was just wondering if that might be a
suitable um thing to propose to assist
uh Miss cable who's obviously approached
more than one occasion I'm still nothing
Force coming I'm sorry to organize the
meeting with directors the leader deputy
and Miss Kayla I think that would be a
problem would it well I was making I
mean make an approach to death a
suitable piece of Correspondence to
support the officers approaches okay
well we could discuss that after the
meeting I mean that's that's been
proposed so that'll depend on officers
time but I've certainly no problem with
it
um
Mr Holmes were you in agreement with
that yes yeah okay right thank you
right okay uh councilor flemingman
councilor Lagan
oh I didn't come in again now
I think there's no more questions
relating to councilor flukers um
statement is there no right yeah we'll
let you back in again
okay we've finished talking about you
now Council of Lucas so um councilor
Fleming
that creature um Leander can I just ask
can we can we use the money I'm thinking
about the Gateway signs that we had
designed or or we as a district council
precluded from doing that thank you
uh councilor Fleming we're pleased to
hear that's a question I asked five
times on the webinars that we attended
to which every time it was ignored
um so that's when the FAQs that were
waiting to have a response on hence my
disappointment and this could greatly
affect what the details within our
investment plan should that be the case
because of living uh if I can just come
back thanks Leander that's quite
interesting
um so maybe we could hand those designs
onto another vehicle perhaps
another organization thank you
I won't make comment on that because
we'll be devising the grant scheme so it
wouldn't be fair for me to to be able to
comment on that I'm afraid Council
Fleming
okay Council 11
yeah thank you chair thanks he's a
cracking report thanks for all your work
you've done so far I'm really happy with
it I think it's a an excellent piece of
work great piece of initiative and can
only be of benefit as long as it's
spread out with a strict criteria the
only comment that I'd make is actually a
proposal to change to recommendation uh
little two where it talks about the the
um and I think it's only right that it
needs to be delegated that an investment
plan delegate the authority the director
of strategy performance and governance
and consult consultation with the leader
of the council chairman of strategy
divorces I think it all should be the
leader of the opposition yeah
because that brings in another view and
and that has a balance to it without
getting Uncle Tom cobley and everyone
involved in it but you've got to keep it
small it's got to be nimble it's got to
be quick so that's a recommendation
awesome thank you okay members are we in
agreement with that um recommended that
term Amendment
okay you're right so um right we'll put
it so that everybody else's asked
questions so we'll put it to the vote
now we've got recommendation little one
that members note the opportunity
presented for investment in the district
by the rural England support fund and
the council's role in securing the
investment and any Administration
on little two that members note the
aggressive piece of work required to
submit the council's rural England
Prosperity fund addendum investment plan
and delegate the authority to the
director of strategy performance and
governance in consultation with the
leader of the council and chairman of
structural resources committee for
development and submission in line with
the government guidance members will be
provided with a further written update
and that's also to include the amendment
made by councilor at Legend on seconded
by councilor siddle but this will also
include the lead of the opposition is
everyone in agreement with these two
recommendations
okay well done members okay and moving
on to agenda item 15. thank you Miss
cable
soft Plastics recycling trial plastic
bags and wrappings pages one four one
and one four four
okay and uh sorry it's Mr Holmes thank
you members this is an exciting project
uh to help support our climate change
strategy and to help manage uh waste and
disposal of Waste and Recycling and from
the district you'll see from the report
itself that our waste contractors sewers
have been engaging in with this
particular project and is taking part in
a a scheme that was actually start to
test and how this type of material is is
collected and recycled
um a quarter of the the waste that is
produced is actually Plastics but only
six percent of that is recyclable so the
department environment Freedom rural
Affairs are actually working on this to
see if they can improve that and it may
well become a requirement for all local
authorities to collect this in a
different way by March 2027 so three
local authorities have been selected for
the first phase and we are one of those
authorities so the scheme will be run um
entirely by sewers and sales they will
make the necessary arrangements for the
collection and obviously the recycling
of the materials collected the
recommendations for you tonight wanted
to inform you that the success and that
this trial going forward and obviously
um to ensure that we actually promote
this with the public and be very clear
on what is required from the public
initially it will be about 25 of the
district and obviously that information
once we understand which parts of the
district are going to be involved in
that um uh will be shared with members
particularly wearing Ward members for
information so I think it's a very
positive report it helps us to to meet
our recycling targets uh and we uh
benefit from the early learning of the
scheme chairman thank you uh thank you
I'd like to say that I'm really pleased
that we're involved in this I think it's
important that we can recycle as much as
we can so I think the fact we've been um
asked to be one of the pilot authorities
I think is a really good pass on the
back for our waste team
um right okay I'll now go to members
I've got cancer Lagann and councilor
stamp yes councilor I have questions Mr
Holmes who how do we get selected as one
of the three
chairman I think that was done through
sewers so I think they actually looked
at all of their contracts to put through
what they thought were the most suitable
so um I think that's how it arises
through the contractor themselves thank
you and just to say what a brilliant
thing thank you
okay and councilor stamp and then
councilor Thompson
um mine is the normal Madam chair where
what area mold and no doubt so um
hopefully it won't be hopefully it will
actually come out to the dingy or to
burn them on Crouch to do to do this or
wherever and not just modern Centric
please thank you
Jim I will obviously report back if I
could hear the views of members and I
can obviously share that throughout the
US team back to sewers but um I'll have
to share with you their best thoughts
when they they come back with that thank
you councilor Fluker um oh sorry and
then councilor Thompson the councilor
fluka first I'll keep away if you want
yeah
I just um just wanted to ask Mr Holmes
um bear in mind that
um you know we have a very very uh good
independent recycling company in in
modern districts in in Malden to be
precise and that members visited the the
site not long ago
um can you reassure members that even
though we're contractually Bound by us
it's County Council that they are
encouraged to engage with that company
because it to me it makes a huge amount
of sense if we can recycle our waste
within the district rather than taking
it out but I do understand there are
contractual obligations but I would have
thought it would have been in
everybody's interest including series to
go there but and it was a very
worthwhile trip I must admit if somewhat
smelly
um do we
um I agree this note yeah thank you
um right okay now I move on to agenda
item 16 and this is split into two parts
A and B and
um 16 a is
um the
um half yearly treasury management
update by Mr Lizzy and this is just for
noting it's purely for noting so Mr
Leslie
as it's for noting I wasn't planning on
speaking but that's fine as well okay
okay Christine b noted okay because
we've all had these reports to read okay
uh agenda item 17 any other items of
business that the chairman of the
community advisor
urgent unfortunately yes there is one is
that coming now or is that added into
one of the Investments the boys
um note that so chicken know that that
won't need to come to this meeting oh
that's good fantastic okay there are
none then no no
um a bit of business that's an urgent
um right agenda item 18 exclusion of the
public and breasts to resolve that under
Section 100a part 4 of The Local
Government Act 1972 the public be
excluded from the meeting for the
following items of business on the
grounds that they involved the likely
disclosure of exempt information is
designed in paragraph three of part one
of schedule 1280 act and that this
satisfies the public interest test all
agreed
okay um
Tara can we turn off the live feed now
please